yoyoyo snapchat guru my hockey here i
love myself a lot even in the face of
crippling self-doubt and a bitch mother
to prove how much I love myself I'm
gonna hit up my favorite date night
restaurant
Ola because when you're comfortable in
your own skin you can be comfortable
anywhere let's go
how many table for one you can leave
this may I get you something to drink
oh yes your best house red Oh make that
two Oh somebody's meeting me here hey
guys well I'm having the best time my
food just got here and lucky me I get to
eat it with my best friend myself are
you kidding Molly my brother I'm just
grabbing a bite to eat in the friendiy
wow that's fun for her yeah it's so
healthy for you to come to our special
place alone you just missed my boyfriend
Gupta he's a doctor so he was paged by
Olivia Munn who is his patient her back
is effed you know anyway I love him
Olivia Munn loves him so everything's
great everything's really really great
with me right now at this time of my
life
okay well it's really good to see ya you
too well bauen drunk
great it went great I'm drunk though oh
you should have seen how comfortable I
was in my own skin
let's break you
you